Next up, let's talk a little bit about the Skeletal Mesh Editor, and talking specifically
about Skinned Animated Mesh Pipeline.
So the editor overview, you'll see some new icons, especially if you're familiar with
Unreal Engine 4 or previous versions.
We got some new icons of how to toggle between each section here.
And when we jump into a workshop demo in a second, you'll see each of these being used.
So the first one, we've got the Skeleton, then we've got the Mesh next to it.
We've got Animations, Animation Blueprint, which we'll touch upon at the end, and then
also the Physics.
So it's very easy to cycle through each of the editor windows from directly inside the
editor, which is a really nice feature of Unreal Engine 5.
When we talk about the Skeletal Mesh Editor, all editors can be accessed with these editor
windows.
So in reference to the previous slide that we were just talking about, if you look at
the top right-hand side of the screen here, you can see the Skeletal Mesh Editor and
the Skeleton, and also the Blueprint and the Physics.
So we can directly hop into each one of these editors from those icons on the top right
there.
So really, really nice.
And the one that we're looking at right here is the Mesh Editor.
So we have a lot of settings pertaining to the mesh.
We got all the materials listed on the right-hand side, for example.
You can set your LODs from here, Morph Targets, and it can all be accessed from this one central
space.
When we're talking about the Skeleton Editor, in this window, you can see that the actual
Skeleton has all the bone names.
So in the bottom left-hand side here, we've got the bone names starting from the root.
You know, when we're talking about that hierarchy, before we see the hierarchy playing a part
and showing where each of the bones are and what they're doing.
So you can also add sockets, which we'll be doing in a second.
You can add virtual bones, change the preview mesh.
We can even preview animations in this window as well, which is a really nice feature.
So you can create different asset types and also manage the animation notify.
So an animation notify might be a certain car tire sound when it hits a certain animation
or something like this, and we can fire all the notifies and especially preview those
animations directly from this window.
So when creating a new asset, we have a few different options available to us.
We can create an animation asset, a new pose.
We can even record animations directly inside of Unreal, which is a really nice feature.
So say you're driving this car around and it's a movable vehicle, you can actually
record that session and have it as an animation, which is a really, really powerful feature.
We can access our animation blueprint as mentioned before, and we can also do composite and montages
as well as the blend spaces and aim offsets.
So these are also available through the mesh editor, just as a quick note.
But yeah, whole host of tools here that are useful to kind of directly dive into from
this window.